what's up guys welcome to this past
whatever today is we have a guest a
guest coming in we're in studio today
and we have a guest coming in Robyn Tran
and she is a comedian and she is also
transgender and I'm not going to pretend
like you know that's not part of the
reason why I want her to come in because
I want to I don't know just see what's
cracking you know besides her you know
sexual origination so so anyway we got
Robin Tran coming in we just shot a
pilot together down in Louisiana and we
got to spend some time around each other
and some of it was just some of the
conversation was interesting and
fascinating and I thought maybe we would
capture some of that today for you guys
thank you guys for listening as always
thank you gray block pizza 18:11 Pico
Boulevard on the way to the beach gray
block you know get that hitter
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for being here today thanks so
much for having me
yeah sorry I seem stressed out no but
now I can tell you that I'm stressed out
are you good yeah we're both stressed
out that's great what's caused it what's
causing you stress is being alive you
know being out of my comfort zone I mean
it's almost like do you live out of your
comfort zone no man I did nothing for
literally like three years and then I
started doing everything oh wow so it's
like I keep missing my bed but then when
I'm in bed I'm like I gotta get the [ __ ]
out of here and do something I gotta get
going I'm actually like ambitious for
the first time in my life
nice yeah I quit marijuana like six
months ago I think that's what happened
Oh that'll Chaney have one of my best
friends uh quit marijuana and says
started one of the biggest clothing
companies in the world oh my god really
yeah jeez
so things can happen you um you were
depressed what was causing the
depression you feel like um half my
family I found out actually this year
half my family has bipolar disorder like
in Vietnam even like it's just like
chemical imbalance and probably I had a
really traumatic childhood you know my
dad drank a lot and my mom had bye buddy
drink do you remember just beer
just like you'd have like ten beers and
I evil yeah and then a Z bowler or no
what's that
was he a bowler like a league bowler no
I don't think he knows what bowling is
even oh wow yeah and it's crazy we
drinking that much beer not know about
bowling yeah I know yeah at least we
would have had fun if he yeah if he knew
about bowling right yeah but my mom and
my mom would like just be gone for a
while and she had to go to like a
hospital cuz you know it was undiagnosed
bipolar oh wow yeah she had that yeah
and so at that point it was just kind of
like willy-nilly they didn't know I mean
that's probably they were still putting
people on valium and things like that or
no yeah yeah I well it's like not talked
about in Vietnamese culture hmm like so
they just so you know we don't know
what's wrong with you you know and then
it took like years for them to finally
go hear some medication you were like
you're sick in the head mmm yeah this is
real funny stuff right yes yes is it
funny is it supposed to be a funny
podcast I feel bad
you know no it's it's just supposed to
be a podcast no it's supposed to be just
a conversation you know what I talked
about anything in particular I just
thought you know it'd be really
interesting unite just work together on
pilot right yeah in Louisiana
yeah and you know and you were like one
of the most unique people I've probably
ever met because you are how do you what
is the term transgender yeah
I'm transgender Vietnamese lesbian I am
a lot of things and you know what sucks
is to be that to be all that and to also
be self aware because like every wish I
wasn't self aware you know I wish that I
didn't know what it looked like all the
time
Wow because like if I wasn't me and I
saw me I'd be like what the [ __ ] that's
the comedian side of you like like I
told you like sometimes I look in the
mirror and I like I get startled like I
forgot that I'm transgender because I
was someone else for 28 years
who were you for 28 years Robert Robert
yeah really angry a little Asian dude
just would yell at audiences for not
laughing and just [ __ ] just like really
overcompensating for something you know
hmm
yeah you don't see I mean I don't feel
like you see a lot of violent Asian
really I mean that except maybe like in
old movies and stuff yeah I don't know a
lot of Asians I feel like I really seem
to be you know Brill like happy people
you get the Filipinos or I think they're
even nicknamed the happy people right
and then you have the Japanese which are
kind of you know a little bit kind of
electronic it seems like a lot of times
like they have you know like you bust
him open too much a gigabytes and fly
can tell you a secret yeah I can't tell
Asian is apart man
you can't know in your Asian yeah I'm a
bad Asian is there bad Asians
yeah I'm one I think you know I kind of
broke I kind of did everything I wasn't
supposed to do like I didn't go to
medical school and I didn't I wasn't the
man you know I'd stay a dude like I
didn't do it right
because in some Asian cultures if they
want they want the boy yeah
oh and usually you're like you're gonna
be like I'll show them I am a boy Red
Rover Red Rover send a vagina right over
yeah exactly yeah so when did you get
because I mean it's just fascinating to
me and one thing that I love about you
like you have this this comedy bit and
we'll put it at the bottom of the video
today and the audio a link where you
were explaining to your mother about you
know how you felt um and is it a woman
trapped in a man's body is that how you
felt or how did you ever feel I just
felt like when when I actually like I
got off like Medicaid you know like I
was medicated for the first time in my
life for antidepressants for my
depressants and you know for the bipolar
and I was singing like this song this is
a girly song and I just like usually I
roll up the window and I do it quietly
but I'm like nah man I'm looking happy
and it's when I did that for the first
time in my life like dude my whole life
flashed before my eyes like me as a kid
I'm wearing pink and like wanting to
play with like this pink hair so said
like these little horses you know like I
remember I kept remembering that and
like wearing jewelry and like I've been
theater art you know drama classes and
they put makeup on me and I would just
leave it on like for days and just like
yeah these these memories came back and
a lot of clues kind of was it like clues
yeah and then I was like man you know if
I was a woman my whole life would make
sense like it wouldn't be a good life
right it would be a life and I think you
know life is like life right but and
then it made sense and I just it was
like a religious experience dude like I
don't know how religious people feel but
the must be like kind of like that my
whole body shivered and I started crying
dude I cried for like half an hour man
and like in my car and then I had to go
clock back into work oh yeah yeah a lot
of chicks have done that dude yeah you
know I mean I think that boy you
definitely qualify yeah no but no that's
fascinating to have like a moment where
you're like this did you almost feel
like you like you're who you really were
like erupted out of yours yeah I think
that's exactly true and you know I
usually remembered this I never looked
at people in the eyes until I came out I
aborted eye contact with everyone except
for my girlfriend like we just looked
down and I didn't never knew why I was
like I think subconsciously it was like
if they see me they might know it about
me but I didn't know what it was you
know what I mean so that's fascinating
so you're afraid if you were looking at
somebody if they saw
that they might see the truth in you
that you didn't even know maybe yeah
that's exactly right yeah yeah it's so
bizarre
I mean it's it's not bizarre that's not
the word I said no I didn't think so but
I think that's so real I think because
that's a reason why a lot of times we
don't look people in the eyes because
we're afraid that they're gonna see our
truth you know they're afraid that we're
gonna see that you know that we're
hurting or that we are confused or
uncertain or sad or yeah you know it's
that's just so it's so what was the song
oh it was like an indie pop song
probably people don't know it was a real
oh Kylie song I don't know if you know
who that is
yeah it's very girly it's it's gay it is
yes it's like that it's raining man song
no no it's kind of it's a different kind
of gay it's like celebrating like this
different femininity not you ever hear
Patrice Tonio talk about It's Raining
Men uh-uh
he says that you know when you're a guy
and you're singing karaoke you gotta
change the lyrics and you're like it's
rain and stuff is rain and things one of
my favorite bits it's rain and stuff so
it's kind of interesting like I was
noticing some stuff and so I'm Robin and
I were working and you were Robert and
now you're Robin yeah yeah and what and
one thing it's so neat and I appreciate
this is like you don't make me feel like
I can't talk to you about these things
you know like you don't make me because
sometimes I get this vibe and this is
just me being honest and this isn't
trying to me be like I know anything but
I get a vibe sometimes by some people
that are you know are out of what would
some people would perceive as the norm
right sometimes we try to engage with
them about a conversation they take that
as being judgmental even like asking
questions and stuff or being curious and
I think it makes some people who are
curious about stuff afraid to ask and
yeah I know I mean I actually I deal
with that too
I think there's like infighting within
the community about how to talk to other
people and stuff um I don't know man I
want to say this but I don't you know
not same and I say stuff on it all the
time it's like a lot of the white ones
really really mad like because they they
didn't have the racial discrimination
before so when they transition this like
this new like they're being
discriminated against now oh so like
it's like a [ __ ] dare taking it all
on at the same time but for me I'm just
like oh yeah discrimination I've
experienced that before I'm just adding
on to it but I'm not down done
downloading the entire thing you know
this is a theory of mine I don't know if
it's [ __ ] true oh I think it's really
fascinating because here you're saying
like oh well if I was black or
Vietnamese I've already experienced some
discrimination yeah so now that I am
switching genders yeah [ __ ] sure like
yeah it's it's still hard but it's like
I'm I'm like I kind of prepared myself
for it you know just by being like Oh
RTI you're like I beat Vietnamese you
know I'll take on the world
that was a plan all along but for a
white person there's like oh [ __ ] dude
everything was great yeah it's just a
theory everybody I do not know know it's
interesting it's a really interesting
theory man it's so funny when you when
you were talking about you know looking
people in the eyes and them seeing did
you know that what you were afraid that
they might see in you was like like your
sexuality or did give in yeah I had a
feeling it was like because like I you
know what I I do I do this with my hands
when I'm in private mmm you know is this
is that's it did I do that sometimes
looking love doing this man just like my
favorite thing I think I was like I
can't hear on the radio she's showing
like a kind of a like a hanging wrist so
yeah yeah little like oh yeah like a
limp wrist or like a walking dead
actually yeah yeah exactly and and I
think I was like man I'm gay am i gay
but I'm not I don't like dudes
you know but I'm not I was like I would
always look at myself like you're not
straight man like so it makes sense that
I'm a lesbian
because like if people say you're not a
lesbian like and they look at me I'm
like well do you think I'm straight then
cuz I don't like dudes you know like
would you look at me and say that's a
straight person
did you have to chart it out because it
sounds like you know for somebody that's
not a good math person it's you're
adding in some different elements ya
know when I when I came out I was like
oh this is gonna be [ __ ] complicated
for people because you came out and you
said I said I'm a woman but I didn't say
I'm a lesbian because I felt weird
saying it at first you know mmm because
of my voice you know like I'm glad
there's a video on this podcast because
like being transgender is not really
great for audio podcast you know people
are like what the [ __ ] I don't I'm
confused
you know and I remember there's a little
girl when Sami had an open mic and she
goes hey that girl sounds like a boy and
I was like oh that's great
you got it completely right little girl
got it right what so we get back on it
what was the bit you the bit you have
about when you explain you're coming out
to my mom coming out to your mom yeah
just like that she doesn't speak
Vietnamese and I don't speak English so
I had to like be like mom in Vietnam but
she doesn't speak English yeah do you
have boy born boy brain girl and she's
like what
and I'm like born boy bring girl she was
okay I don't know sometime you know and
I'm like okay me that I don't wanna do
that do you want me to do the whole no
it's good we'll post it below it's just
a great story yeah it's it's just so
interesting it for you it's like born
boy brain girl it's like that's just
like the simplest yeah you know it's a
simple way to put it for somebody
yeah is you have to make it simple
because if you don't speak the same
language it has to be like the most
simple words and also I don't know the
complicated way to explain it yeah so I
guess like we just yell it for an hour
you got it so I came which is also a
very popular Vietnamese exactly yeah
they're very quiet like amongst
strangers but to each other is like man
why are you guys yelling at each other
oh you guys having fun or you guys mad
at each other like the same thing yeah
they're very Game of Thrones
yeah I'm like who's a Lannister in this
[ __ ] I thought it was nap time
right yeah um that's so while do you
feel because I'm trying to thing so we
went down to Louisiana together right
and I'm trying to think of how I think
and feel about like
like how if I if if there are certain
things that I think of you as a certain
gender or you know like if without even
choosing to yeah you know not if not a
judgment but just like cuz I think of
you as a young lady yeah you know but I
guess sometimes I would treat you like a
man right is that kind of a common like
do you notice anything not in the even
just in the way I behave towards you but
I think I noticed it more with like you
didn't know me before my transition
right so like people that know me after
yeah they treat me with like a little
more of this respect because I think I
think it's the voice I really do I think
like I present pretty feminine I I still
uh not completely but it's easier for
people right but what I notice is that
from people before my transition you
know like at open mics the comedian's
like hang around in a circle and they
talk [ __ ] on each other they don't do
that with me anymore cuz they're too
scared ah and I think it's like a loss
you know like oh man I love talking [ __ ]
yeah but they're afraid of like stepping
on eggshells and singing the wrong thing
and misgendering me and stuff because
they knew me as Robert right so it's
harder for them I think when you dream
at night D dream like as do you notice
if you dream like in a male or female
perspective or if that's nice I don't I
don't dream as myself usually so yeah I
don't know sometimes I think I have I am
Robert but you know I don't know do you
remember like a first night that you
went to sleep and felt like you were a
woman because I mean I think yet just
and do you know probably slept with a
smile for the first time yeah yeah oh I
can't imagine how like rely like freeing
it would be yeah you know cuz there were
times in my life for there have been
times in my life where you know I was
having such a tough time like relating
getting into a relationship and being
like comfortable in a relationship that
I thought it might be gay you know when
I'm like well is something you know I
mean after like there was nine years
where I wasn't in any sort of a
relationship with a woman I was dating
yeah you know he's jerking off on you
know mutually jerking off after people
that agreed
buddy was okay with me jerking off in
the room great um you know with women
and stuff like that and doing some sex
but I wasn't you know I wasn't able to
like love and lock down anything there
yeah and so I was like man well maybe I
you know could I be gay and I just don't
know it like I'm such a bad judge of
character yeah that I don't even know if
I'm gay yeah but then I realized over
time that for me I do desire a strong
connection a male connection but what I
want is like a brotherly connection yeah
and that's something I've always really
you know missed and a fatherly
connection so I really gravitate towards
some moments like that with other males
to have some camaraderie yeah but that
you know I was just I was just lacking a
connection with my own mother and so
that's you know hampered a the ability
to connect with women beyond anything
sexually and right yeah you know that's
really I feel kind of bad for guys that
you know you can't have that camaraderie
cuz it's like it's kind of like oh are
we gay you know like you can't just I
still have some male qualities just out
of habit and there was a guy that um I
want used to go to this Wellness Center
you know for like to get better and
there was this guy that helped me every
day we talked every day about comedy and
stuff we became like best friends hmm
but I never hugged him it was because it
was like in my head I'm like is that gay
to hug him even though I'm not like I'm
like a woman in my head but still feels
like the old guy is still there like
just lurking just can't be friends you
know what I mean like it's we're too
close and we're not like a reasonable
it's a date now you know like it's that
feeling you know guys don't the guys
aren't like allowed to get close with
each other like that hmm yeah yeah there
is there's like a weird thing sometimes
you know yeah like if I Pat my buddies
on the back I'll do a bit like aw can't
Pat him again today right you used it up
for the day I use not Pat up today
because you know that's the fat rule
I can thumbs up and from real close you
know I can do point blank range thumbs
up all day but I can't I can't do an
extra pad yeah was there some strange
moments like
I mean this is just do you ever feel
like in the future we will all be that
things will be more fluid and that you
were like a pioneer on this sort of
horizon of you know gender ship if that
makes any sense you know III was
thinking about that and is either gonna
be like everyone is kind of a flew fluid
or that it's gonna be so many that you
can pick from or something hmm but as
for the pioneer thing I actually just
like my my dream is for it to be boring
you know to not be like like you're
brave or to be like you're you're the
worst thing like the YouTube comments or
probably for this video like I feel like
I'm not gonna read them you know and
like that you can't have you can't be a
woman of you gotta dig a lot of thumbs
up for it you know I already know they
didn't even watch the video you know but
I also have the other one like words
like you're so you're so brave and it's
like oh man don't call me brave man like
right I'd really just live in my life
like I told you I forget I'm transgender
sometimes like just like Alan always
people why are people looking at me oh
[ __ ] I'm wearing a dress oh my god
looking for God man like I'm already
depressed about something else and now I
gotta think about this [ __ ] you know
yeah yeah you really like for a comedian
already to be afflicted with whatever it
is it makes us want to be comedians yeah
you know whatever like toil or like
broken like piping or whatever inside of
us that you know makes us covet that
constant attention yeah and then to be
like oh well yeah I know what I'm gonna
add on to this I had to throw away all
my load materials did you yeah I was
really I was up on stage and now you
said it on stage one day is like hey I
don't I'm not joking guys but feel like
a woman and I don't know if him to start
wearing skirts because I'm lazy and
that's uh I don't know what I'm gonna
say tonight so have a good night
everyone
that was it I put the mic back in the
mic stand and left like people were like
holy [ __ ] like this is for hot we're
kidding and I'm like no I'm not Andy
Kaufman dude I don't
I'm kidding [ __ ] you know and that was
how I came out to my comedian friends
that I just did on stage did it have you
ever has anybody ever accused you of it
being like a thing
oh yeah sure like um I think someone was
making fun of me I forgot who it was
where I was like Robin is gonna just
start adding afflictions like just to
you know get more people to go get
behind her like right on the leg yeah
next week she can't walk like she's
blind
like just adding on more she's a service
animal Robin you're taking it too far
yeah of course do you was it were you
attracted to women at a certain point in
your life yeah feel like you were yeah I
was always attracted to women and I
always felt like one I remember thinking
when I was a kid like man I wish I could
be a lesbian dude like out of everything
else like no I just loved like I saw
like Ellen DeGeneres kissed some woman
on TV and do that was like like I I got
so horny when I saw that it was like you
know like when you remember like the
first thing you saw where I'm like I
don't know what jacking off is yet but
if I can jack off it's gonna be to that
kind of [ __ ] so even to this day just
women making out I'm just like [ __ ] man
I got a jackoff like so like that's my
favorite thing you know I don't think
that was what you were asking me like no
I think it's well it's like I mean I
guess I just wanted in no kind of year
where your attraction was you know cuz I
mean cuz then you have to Connor I'm
sure like as you're trying to figure out
what your place is or what your escape
from whatever you know you did you feel
trapped
I always felt trapped yeah yeah I think
I think you're right yeah I don't know
how else to put it but it's just like I
just felt like like an escape room
you're not gonna win escape room no I
haven't been to one but you know what it
is yeah it's like where there's clues
and then suddenly you get out but then
it's just you and your friends back in
the lobby of a Hilton there son
yeah I kind of feel like I just wanted
to scream and I didn't know why mmm I
would say that's how I felt
wow yeah and do you still feel some of
that
no no IIM now sometimes I get like the
identity crisis of just like Who am I
like as a person who's not as depressed
anymore because I'm kind of getting over
that too soon do you notice that this is
helped ease your depression yeah no no
no that's separate the two things are
separate oh they are yeah that's what's
so [ __ ] up about it like um I'm not as
you know blown away by the gender thing
anymore it's been three years I guess
kind of boring for me personally you
know and then like I'm like okay now I'm
a depressed transgender person or
whatever you know and then and then like
the depression has lifted a little bit
or a lot mm-hmm so now I'm like well who
am i if I'm not depressed I guess I just
have to figure it out day by day gets do
things you know you know and be active
like I can't believe that I we did the
thing in Louisiana yeah I can't believe
I did I went from doing nothing to that
the most fun three days of my life yeah
it was really the most fun days in my
whole life yeah that's cool yeah I wish
I you know I yeah I mean I there was a
moment where you and I are driving like
that Grand Marquis down on that Highway
I mean because we went back to Covington
in my hometown I talked about this I'm a
regular podcast a little bit last week
but I didn't tell them that you know I
said I was here with another comedian
Robin Tran but I didn't tell them that
you know you had a sexual transition or
you know get in any of that but I told
him that I was back there and you know
it was pretty wild and that Wendy was
like yeah like we were down there and it
was yeah we were just cruising all
around like Scully I'm older just like
you know a recovering rural yeah guy and
uh and a new transgender comedian you
probably the first the craziest thing
I've seen in that town yeah actually had
a three-legged pony growing up yeah okay
maybe it was that she was a real beaut
no you know I actually almost blew the
whole thing the first day I expected
yeah you know my eyes a little red right
now there's a reason for that like half
an hour before they were gonna pick me
up I took what I think is my bladder
medication because I got a PA lot hmm
and I look at the pillow dude it I took
my [ __ ] sleeping pill
no like and it's like it knocks you out
after an hour and I just look at Kate
like I took a [ __ ] lunesta
and she's like you gotta throw it up
yeah right like she's like a coach for
like the worst sport ever you know she's
on them all bulimia team yeah like I'm
over the toilet I'm [ __ ] crying I'm
like I blew it
she's like this right before they come
and pick you up for the first day issue
yeah is she's like she's like put your
[ __ ] finger down your throat I'm like
Gus fring from Breaking Bad like putting
my finger down my throat snow nothing's
working she goes think of disgusting
things think of [ __ ] disgusting
things and that's not working she goes
think of the most disgusting thing you
can think of and I thought about eating
my mom's [ __ ] then it all came out
[ __ ] crying because I'm thinking
about and then like 10 minutes later
everyone picked me up I'm like hey
everyone like it's nothing but in my
head I'm like that was like I'm
traumatized by it you know I'm it was
the most traumatizing woman in my life
and then the most fun 3 days of my life
like here we go yeah damn I never know
anybody just get all hopped up on
lunesta yeah it's a hell and then that's
why I popped a blood vessel by throwing
up oh really
yeah there are thoughts gonna die one
time in Chicago if I eat tuna fishing
Gatorade at the same time I'll [ __ ]
my throat closes up oh my god really I
can't handle that much excitement you
know just [ __ ] fish oil and uh you
know whatever Illinois electrolytes yeah
Wow I should all throw up of this shut
down so I literally was having uh I was
[ __ ] crawling through the hall of a
hotel in Chicago pulling on the dress of
a cleaning lady and like had my hand
down my throat oh I just wanted that I
wanted to do sex or sex like this is the
weirdest mating call I've ever seen in
my life
or just holding my throat open it's like
this is a weird yeah yeah okay God will
upgrade you to a suite do you feel
sometimes I go do you feel like a woman
now sometimes I feel like like like man
I feel like a woman but I'm [ __ ]
getting lazy
I don't like I have to put makeup on and
I got a [ __ ] wear dresses like I've
done it for three years so like I
started buying like boy clothes again
yeah
oh just cuz yeah cuz a lot of women that
ended up getting lazy just by boy stuff
yeah they're like oh I'm just a sports
fan and yeah
like a tomboy kind of you know and I
don't know kind of things like the
initial novelty wore off and I mean
novelty not like oh this whole thing is
like a like a stunt or anything like
that but you know you you just kind of
get over the it's called gender euphoria
mmm and then you experience as a gender
euphoria and I think when it goes away
you're like okay now I don't have to
always wear a [ __ ] dress can I get to
wear a [ __ ] t-shirt and jeans and
like light makeup and stuff yeah did you
find yourself having like really a over
drawer over dressing like wearing like a
bride's outfit a couple of days a week
and stuff yeah I I would over a dress
every time I just wear dresses and
[ __ ] nice clothes and these shoes
from be as Lady as possible yeah from
Nordstrom's you know like this expensive
shoes and [ __ ] like was there guys that
you like had no before when you were
Robert that you were like oh that guy's
kind of cute that you were like you know
just trying to just offer to just [ __ ]
and [ __ ] like that
oh you mean guys that I knew before yeah
well over you were lesbians who were
attracted to women yeah well I mean I
there are the other side though like
there are some guys that were like hey
like they want to hit it well you know
if I were attracted to you would that
make me gay you know hypothetically and
I'm like it's weird hypothetical
question did you know Facebook message
me at 3 in the morning you know man you
know I guess it doesn't like if I'm a
woman so it doesn't actually make you
gay like I actually like had to look it
up and not weird gosh yeah if you like
if you are a guy that thinks transgender
women you're not gay hmm yeah so if I
dated y'all wouldn't be gay yeah people
would think you are though right
everyone would call UK so it's like you
would be gay anyway well you know it's
funny I don't feel like like if I feel
like if here's a here's interesting I
noticed this if you were sitting here
and you were a man yeah I would feel
like oh if I dated Robert yeah I would
be gay right but if I sitting here and
I'm just thinking about you oh if I
dated her yeah I might be you know a
real wild
cat yeah you know what I'm saying I
might be in a hunting rare game but I uh
haha you know but I don't I don't have
the same feeling yeah that's kind of
interesting
yeah it is yeah just because my total
like you know if you put you next to a
boy I'll be like oh well I would you
know I think a lot of people like on
like I'll read periscope comments about
me and stuff and it like yeah what does
that thing you know when people are like
that mad I'm just like alright dude like
I I don't think it's true when people
were like they hate trans people it
means they're attracted to them but the
ones that get really [ __ ] mad I'm
like you kind of want to [ __ ] a
transgender woman and be like why would
you get that mad you know if people just
went ill yeah and it's like okay you
just don't like the way I look yeah but
just to [ __ ] that what don't [ __ ] is not
doing oh my god like you know like
they're like their brains are gonna go
yeah but you know like okay do you want
a wo fans yeah like a New World Order
fan so you press that and turn it back
on New World Order fans maybe I'm a huge
wrestling fan are you
oh yeah dude I like I know more about
wrestling than I do about anything else
in my life combined oh wow I've been
watching wrestling since I was four
years old and how old do you know I'm 31
yet I was a huge when this is a little
bit for you but I was a huge the Von
Erichs were like a big I know I know
history
yeah no body butters there was the Texas
tornado yeah WWF he like transferred
over yeah like the the like he would
spin around and do a clothesline or a
punch Kerry Von Erich Kerry Von Erich
and he was the handsomest one outside of
that they got a little kind of animal II
looking yeah one of the brothers like a
damn sheep call sheep who was one of you
favorite wrestlers growing up it was
always Shawn Michaels man oh yeah BK I
think is the greatest wrestler like that
ever lived in Marty Jannetty know it's
so sad Marty Jannetty is always like
referenced even nowadays is like if
there's a tag team and one of them
explodes and one of them doesn't
they call him the Marty Jannetty of the
oh isn't that yeah I don't know yeah
both Ahmed nice hair do you think it was
something about wrestling that kind of
had that that has that sort of trans
appeal to it in a weird way no I think
you know what I think it's completely
separate from gender I love I love
combat I don't know why you know I love
roast battles and I love wrestling and
I'd here's a movie called changing lanes
with
I'm Jackson and Ben Affleck and they're
just like trying to one-up each other
with like trying to [ __ ] each other's
lives up and I don't know why I just
love that like being boastful like I can
[ __ ] you up and I can back it up and
other guys like know I can [ __ ] you up
and just watching them try to [ __ ] each
other up yeah I love it this is my
favorite thing in the world but I don't
like people actually getting hurt so
yeah that's why I like that it's like
stage that's why I can't watch like UFC
mmm like oh that guy's legs really
broken man like the fun's over man I'm a
you kind of [ __ ] that guy's wife and you
pretend to hit each other oh that's
what's [ __ ] awesome but like oh man
that guy's leg became like rubber I'm
like oh Jesus man [ __ ] real can't
deal with that do you things that you
like more now after your transition that
you didn't like before like do you
notice no no I like pretty much all the
same things and I don't know like I
still like wrestling as much as I ever
did I was afraid I would stop liking
wrestling oh you know and then like what
would I get so scary like yeah where
there are things you were afraid like
you of losing you know you're free
you're gonna lose this or lose that if
you go into this dude if I lost
wrestling I don't know what I would do
with my time I spent I spend you know
WWE Network I spent hours just watching
that every day mm-hmm you know you know
WrestleMania was just like last week in
Louisiana you know I didn't I love it I
love it more than it's like number four
and my list of things I love in my life
like you know family my girlfriend me
and leg wrestling yeah that's most of
America yeah you just described yeah
did did you um did you experience like
any loss of like friends or any
connections that really changed or
evolved for the better in your life yeah
I lost a lot of friends and I don't know
some of it was because of the
transgender thing but some of it was
like when I came out like all of us in
10 people unfriended me right away and
then like I posted a picture of me in a
dress and some guy went like it's some
guy I knew in high school we knew each
other for years anyway anyway is this
for work or something and I went no man
I'm a woman and bad [ __ ] up and he
[ __ ] unfriended me no I was like a
[ __ ] heartbroken well maybe his wife
doesn't want to
but another guy actually looked at one
of the pictures and he liked he liked
like nine in a row you know when someone
like likes like a bunch of your pictures
in a row and then one of them I wasn't
really made up with these big boots and
he goes well he's went [ __ ] you for this
one Robert and then and then unfriended
me so I think he like jerked off and
felt bad you know I mean like why would
he like a bunch of pictures and say [ __ ]
you for this one and then unfriend me
right oh the boots dude a lot of people
that foot fetish you know oh yeah oh
there's a guy around me growing up
hidden he couldn't even come unless a
pair of Justin's were in the room I
think I'm a lot of like regretful coming
sessions I think people have jerked off
to me and then felt really embarrassed
afterward and you I am four people have
you always jerked off to the same stuff
oh no I jerk off to like weirder [ __ ]
now oh yeah oh yeah so you find that has
that evolved or devolved no I'm and
you're I've jerked off to like my own
pictures yeah I'm like man if I had a
clone have you yeah it's cool I mean
I've never done it yeah
when I was growing up they had a dude if
we didn't even have pornographer when I
was young and we couldn't get any mags
yeah but they had this dude named Nick
and he would draw you a little picture
of some cooter for the weekend you know
yeah so for four dollars he'd hit this
dude Nick up on Friday you know or
Thursday night if you wanted a good
sketch no cuz if he had that extra time
to work on it man and then Friday get
that hitter you know need jerk off all
weekend
I still think it's not as weird as
jerking off to her selfie but now
whatever Oh yours is definitely weirder
I'm just trying to make you feel a
little less uncomfortable no what is it
about a selfie that can make you call me
thing I was like man I never looked like
that before
you know and then I'm really happy with
how I look oh she will take a really
nice picture yeah and then jerk off to
that yeah I don't I haven't done it for
a while so maybe my self-esteem is lower
do you feel like one of my buddies used
to get a cake used to get a cake and put
like you're a good guy Matt on it he get
that written on it and then eat it at
home by himself yeah he's kind of like
that yeah kind like that but what your
day yeah so do you still have a penis
yeah and do you take drugs like what is
that whole kind of thing like or is it
that that's not even part of it
and this is just good information for
people because there's a lot of people
that don't know yeah I I am actually
afraid to take any extra medication
they're like hormones and stuff because
I take a lot of medication for the
bipolar okay so I don't take any
medication and I haven't gotten any
surgery it's more I just dress up and I
just like try to you know make my hair
look as feminine as possible okay yeah
do you feel like it could have just been
and I don't mean this in a bad way but
I'll just mean it sound like in a
curious way that it could have this
could be like some part of the bipolar
thing do you ever have to think about
that though do you question that ever or
is it not even the same no I think what
I think it actually kind of bothers me
that I think that's the misconception
because um like I think like it's in
America it's hard to look at people like
with multiple oppressions you know it's
always like well that guy is oppressed
because he's you know black but maybe
he's also bipolar you know but people
only can see black you know or like you
know like when you look at mental health
issues like on TV it's mostly white
people because that's like they can only
look at one at a time mm-hmm like if you
have Vietnamese and bipolar it's like
too much like they can look at and
transgender well like pick one because
we can only focus on one on TV
so like mine are all separate mm-hmm
like I don't I don't think it's like
related at all you know what I mean
right so you don't know but you don't
feel like inside of you like and I don't
know what it feels like to be bipolar
you know I've seen some friends that
have come down and been afflicted with
it as they got a little bit older out of
high school but you didn't think like oh
maybe I'm just bipolar at first or
something there wasn't any of that
no I I thought like maybe this will help
and then we're gonna help my depression
for a while like I got out of it for a
while and then he you know came back
because you know I wasn't taking the
right medication but just coming out
helped me like for three months I didn't
need anything I was just like really
happy so Kim you do you feel like you
can see when other people might have the
same thing going on yeah I do
Wow I was like yeah I think that well I
see it with like
you're like the the hormone whisperer
yeah I see it like there's a woman
friend I have I'm like I'm like she's a
dude like the way she acts the way she
talks like she's not a tomboy man she's
a [ __ ] dude but her name start with a
G or not no okay I can't I can't say
yeah we won't outer but I just thought
it might be the same person we're just
gonna stop there at that first letter
yeah yeah do you do you I'm just trying
to get I guess gets in do you feel like
like did you feel like we're Louisiana
that people thought differently than
anywhere else or do you feel like when
you went there that you might be looking
for that yeah you know I was surprised
by how how little people seem to give a
[ __ ] about the transgender thing you're
better than it you definitely
better-looking than half the were in
there did did I tell you that I think
they were thrown out by myath in the
city more because of several people like
[ __ ] bowed
like I think the mayor about someone
told me maybe check out the mayor bowing
to you so what I saw the joke that I've
kind of come up with is I think they
were thrown off that I was Vietnamese
and now they they just have a weird
stereotype about Vietnamese we were like
oh hey I didn't know that Vietnamese do
dress up like chicks hell I ain't judgin
I think that that's what they were
thinking I don't think they knew that I
was a transgender woman mm-hmm
but yeah I used Vietnamese was was way
more uh nonetheless and I thought they
were gonna give me dirty looks but no
one did oh wow
yeah me not worried about it some too
you know that people would I mean I
didn't think so but you just don't know
yeah I mean are getting so divert places
a lot of places are getting more diverse
nowadays you know or at least more
multicultural right like I think the
gender stuff is still probably kind of
rare yeah you know probably people are
afraid to talk about it yeah it's really
new I think well and it's not new
because it's been going on for actually
thousands of years like Native Americans
used to have a third gender oh yeah like
two-spirit you know for I think that was
the transgender back in the day that
double up yeah that's what they call it
the double up and sexy and but but now
you know it's new like now
like we're finally talking about it it's
new in that sense do you ever worry that
you will wake up one day and feel
differently yeah because then I'll have
to transition back and I think I'm I'm
so this is how Aragon I am I think I'm
so good I'd be able to pull it off
you know but I'm not a dude you know
like you're the David Copperfield um
there are moments when I'm like I wish I
was a guy it would be a lot easier you
know so that's how that's how I kind of
know I'm a woman because it would be so
much easier to switch back my life would
be a lot easier it would yeah I don't
have to put makeup on every day don't
have to like worry about people looking
at me or sending me weird messages on
Facebook or anything you know he's walk
around like kind of like I'm invisible
did you feel more invisible before oh
absolutely yeah no one looked at me like
being transgender and had a death he did
that feel certain did that kind of like
hurt your feelings some no it's like you
don't know that you feel invisible
because you're you this is like your
reality all the time it's like I'm you
know a fish in water doesn't know it's
in water right yeah like a goldfish in a
bowl they don't know they're in there
yeah the world yeah so I think like now
I I miss it a little bit because now
when I walk into the store people like
look at me and stuff it's like you're
like a celebrity that people look but do
people don't know who you are
mm you know what I mean um it's almost
like The Wizard of Oz Yeah right like
you heard he's back there in the
beginning of the movie but then they get
there and he's kind of not even around
yeah yeah that's who I am yeah um do you
like have any thoughts like when it
comes like families and stuff like that
like having a family did you have any
thoughts that changed I'm just trying to
think I'm trying to really I guess get
into what that's like a little bit uh
you know if your thoughts kind of are
you just the same person but you're just
it you look like a woman now I think
that's more like that yeah I said more
like I'm the same person except I'm I
just kind of embrace my feminine
qualities like I do the limp wrist thing
and I mean and I don't care that my
voice sometimes like sounds like kind of
you know girly or whatever you know I
don't care I don't I'm not trying to be
macho anymore ah like yeah my friend
told me like to get a girlfriend he goes
like you're too
you're too flowy you know to get a
girlfriend you gotta like walk like this
and I'm like putting up my shoulders
right now like oh yeah you'll get [ __ ]
if you do this all is calm and it's
really stiff man like I can't I can't do
that all the time
so that's the main difference I think
was there a girl or something you had
apologized to that you hooked up with
before no no there have been girls I've
had to apologize for other reasons yeah
yeah but it has nothing to do with the
gender did you feel like immediately you
could get in some legit fights with
[ __ ] before that you couldn't get
into I didn't think about the fighting
aspect of it like if you hit a girl now
are you off the hook or you're still
Robert hit that [ __ ] I don't know I
just wouldn't feel right to hit a woman
would you have felt I mean yeah look I
agree yeah you know I'm not out here you
know I'm not you know supporting that
but did you feel any differently before
that's a really interesting question
no I feel actually feel exactly the same
way as I did before like it would be as
wrong well what did your father think
about it oh my dad he would he
transgender what do you mean as my son
where's that for comedy he still thinks
that yeah after three years even though
he sees me like this sometimes like he's
walking around it's like he it's like he
sees like a [ __ ] censored person or
something he doesn't even acknowledge it
god that must be crazy and fun to be in
that brain just how everything just kind
of whatever yeah he doesn't know he
raised two lesbians you know oh [ __ ] I
shouldn't have said that on the air
that's okay pretending your sister isn't
allege yeah look Oh everybody's pretty
much do you feel like it we're all gonna
be lesbian soon yeah that's exactly I
mean I think everyone should be yeah
yeah it just makes sense I don't know I
just think women are beautiful and I
love women so much you know like to look
like this and sound like this and to say
that I love women what sucks is that you
know it's been portrayed as if you're a
guy and you're straight on TV and you're
like oh I love women and it's like oh
that's a gay dude he's suppressing it
but like I actually sound and talk like
that and I like women but I don't like
dudes and it's hard to prove that when
you sound and talk like this you know
what I mean yeah you have to prove to
you have to prove like you have a
girlfriend now right do you have to
prove that you had a penis at first were
you like look I promise I got a dick in
here somewhere or do you know like like
did she know she know she stuck with me
through the transition oh your girl
force with you before yeah she was with
me as Robert and then she stuck with me
through the transition yeah we have a
show about it we do the unconventional
lesbians show we talk about our whole
relationship and how I wear kind of
watch that hat
we perform like oh you got your sh f is
a stage yeah yeah we have one coming up
in June I think okay yeah yeah we'll put
the link into that yeah if you if I were
like what kind of person out there would
maybe have the same thing that you have
like what clues would they have if they
had this you know if they had this kind
of wild condition I think is it as a
wild condition is that it no I don't
think that's the correct way to put it
but I I would say that the most
important thing for me is that
everyone's journey is kind of different
you know like some people who have not
had the experience I had words like I
always knew and then I didn't know some
people just kind of figured it out one
day and I I kind of don't ask people how
they figured it out I guess doesn't
matter right now yeah I guess doesn't
matter to me is there still something
that like did you get into the gay
lesbian community kind of latched like
was there do you feel like there's a
whole connection there do you feel like
not connected to that world do you just
feel like you're on your own path no I I
was surprised by how open they were to
me they like welcomed me with open arms
you know know as I'll never forget that
they did that for me I needed I needed I
needed like a new family words basically
and they were my family for a while but
Ana
not as much anymore I think I think I'm
figuring out who I am and I'm he's kind
of I don't like to be put in a box you
know like I'm kind of like someone that
likes to say something for the first
time uh yeah yeah yeah and that's like
has nothing to do with gender I just my
arrogance you know so like got put in a
box by society I'm transgender and the
new transgender people were like oh this
is how you do it I'm like no [ __ ] you
I'm not gonna I'm gonna be like so I'm
the buzz all yeah man I'm not even yeah
I'm different than all you transgender
people huh yeah would be before yeah
feel even more different than you so
that's where I am right now
do you ever worry or fear not even worry
but do you ever think [ __ ] you know like
maybe that's a part of what even led me
into this was just an ego to really be
unique no no absolutely not I know it's
real because like dude you know how like
people who were like hate gay people
like end up being gay I was like dude I
hated trans people like I [ __ ] hated
them mmm I got to watch you like my
girlfriend tried to get me to watch
transparent on Amazon mm-hmm and I was
just watching it and I was screaming at
the TV like what would [ __ ] I have to
call this dude she would kind of [ __ ]
world is this now just like yelling you
know like yell at the TV and then and
then as I'm yelling I don't remember I
said this and I'm like you know in some
kind of life I would have been called I
would have asked people to call me she
that would be [ __ ] awesome but you
don't see me [ __ ] whining about it
and it feels like she's like are you
transgender and I was a guy don't
[ __ ] want to talk about I slammed the
door I don't remember I said that so
it's almost like this alternate you said
it yeah
and did you ever feel like a little
woman inside you like crying out for
help or crying out to be noticed or any
of those I didn't feel like any of that
stuff yeah I don't know what that would
feel like did you ever see a movie and
be like oh yeah I don't want to [ __ ]
that cartoon or something like brave
know nothing Braves hot or not who's
brave brave is like this gin she's like
an Irish Archer and she was a like a
child star on Disney or something like
but it's a cartoon it's a drawing not a
real child sounds like you think that
she's hot is it okay to say I'll [ __ ] a
cartoon but not knowing what age it is I
don't know I guess we'll figure out a
little bit worried about that all of a
sudden I remember I watched this movie
called The Joy Luck Club
and it was like all Asian women and dude
that maybe that movie made me cry like
nine times man I was well I just watch
it and I would relate to these Asian
women but I'm like that's weird I'm not
an Asian woman but that's like the movie
that I watched that I'll think about all
the time mmm yeah why because something
is a feeling in there then them you must
really relate to yeah like the not being
listened to and by society and you know
the things that Asian we might have to
go through and yeah is this like weird
like I don't remember the specifics but
I remember like I can put myself in
their shoes and like that's how I would
feel and then it feels tragic you know
like did you feel like you used to hurt
a lot more now you don't yeah actually
yeah
a lot of my women friends weren't really
surprised when I came out they were like
oh my god that makes so much sense
because like they would always tell me
it's like you think like a woman because
we would talk about life and stuff and
they would talk about boys and I would
talk about girls and the way I talked
about girls it was like different than
any guy they knew cuz I wouldn't I
wouldn't you know be like oh yeah like
her whenever I'd be like man the way
that she oh my god oh my god oh my god
like look look at what she look at what
she I am to me look at what she I am to
me
what do you think I think this means
like [ __ ] girls no [ __ ] you I like
her a lot I like her a lot dude you were
local all this time you thought you had
a lot of friends were girls you were
low-key trying to [ __ ] em all but as a
woman yeah you know what's funny is no I
wasn't trying to [ __ ] them all and
that's kind of what a different Lake my
guy friends wouldn't understand I had a
lot of female friends and I was
attracted to all of them but they would
always be like you want to [ __ ] all your
female friends and I'm like no I
actually I don't like I like their
company they'd be like oh so you're
saying right now if so and so it's like
I want to [ __ ] you you'd say no and I'm
like I didn't say I would say no I'm
saying that I don't doesn't think it's
like no if you wouldn't say no like I
think guys look at it like more black
and white yeah and the women look at it
more gray yeah I'm like I can be
attracted to someone and not want to
[ __ ] them you
and then like if they wanted to [ __ ] me
I might have a weak moment or whatever I
think that's more that's more than more
female yeah that's how I still look at
it
I was at this party one time and this
dude wanted to hook up with this chick
really bad and everybody's drunk and
she's like if you let my friend who is
homosexual blow you then I'll [ __ ]
hook up with you right he's like all
right you know so this dude blew him and
then she didn't let him dude hook up
with her oh that's okay did he have a
good time huh did he enjoy himself I
mean you know it was I think fourth of
July but the thing is that I remember
there was this one game this fraternity
played I went up to and it was at UM
this was in Ithaca New York they had a
school up there called Cornell or
Kearney Cornelius I don't know
Cornelius maybe Cornelius Academy
Cornell Cornell which one sounds right
Cornell okay big red or something was
there a [ __ ] team name right stupid
but they had this game called don't wake
the bunny and it was they would put tick
marbles put him in a dude's ass that was
passed out oh no I woke him ha ha you
know had to drink or whatever you know
this guy wakes up and has 9 steelies in
his ass you know why isn't that
considered gay
that's very gay drawing dicks on your
friends faces and [ __ ] you know they're
calling me gay because I'm hearty dude
that's Native American culture I think
that's a Native American culture yeah
has Chris had a question too we're
talking about when I was driving in
Chris what was that question you win it
as oh yeah if I'm as respected okay so
um I feel like people who don't who
don't see me perform respect me a lot
less mmm like they haven't seen me do
comedy yet I'm like a caricature of a
person but when they've seen me perform
they do this switch and and they'll make
sure that they'll say this like it's
funny every single person says it's like
wow you're really funny you know what
trans has nothing to do with it
you're just funny you know [ __ ] transit
[ __ ] you you're just a funny promise
said that yeah like it doesn't even
matter and I'm like I didn't say it
mattered you know hang it up so it's
like I'll never get a fair assessment
and so like um back then when I went on
stage right just a little asian dude
little Robert yeah a little Robert would
go on stage and people would be people
would start laughing already because
it's like Asian people aren't funny so
the bar so the so the bar would be
really low but do you have this crazy
also self-hatred for Asian people like
if I say Haitian people I usually think
they're pretty funny Japanese people
seem like they're asleep but also alive
at the same time but every other type of
Asian amazing is really funny no I don't
I don't think I think I think that
that's a rare assessment of Asian people
though like this is how I feel like if
you're if you're Asian you go on stage
if you can put a complete sentence
together the audience will kind of laugh
because they're like woah I didn't know
an Asian could put jokes together you
know like that's kind of the race but
like it's like you get like advantage
it's due to racism and so now I get an
extra advantage because I'm trans cuz
they're like oh my god this trans person
it's actually funny like it surprises
them so at the end they're like really
blown away hmm I think black people have
the opposite problem like I remember
this black guy was at an open mic and
the bartender was like I think this guy
is gonna be funny yeah and I'm like you
saying that cuz he's black oh yeah yeah
he was just like a Rick he's like a
brand new comic doing a bomb because
he's [ __ ] brand new you know like
people were like oh man I thought that
was gonna be like the new [ __ ] Chris
Rock or something you know yeah there's
a lot of expectations that feel like on
black people yeah it's like you know
it's like with basketball you know like
you see a tall black guy you're like
that dude definitely plays basketball or
unfortunately works at the airport yeah
like that's the way it's you know
there's just there's definitely some you
know stereotypes that are out there I
can't believe that little Asian this
little do you think Robert was a cool
guy now that you're Robin no I think
Robert had moments the I think Robert
tried his best but definitely like
hurt a lot of people you know cow just
said mean things when I was mad you know
when I would be mad at people and not
knowing people as boundaries and like
you know like a girl would block you on
uh name mm-hmm hey I am I don't know
about that but yeah I could imagine like
you know you get blocked and then you
get a new screen name and be like why
did you block me like I would do [ __ ]
like that man it was [ __ ] like Robert
oh oh - yeah but um yeah you know I'm
gonna go back to the comedy thing for a
second I think I got a chip on my
shoulder okay about my stand-up cuz I
think I'm really good you know like I
don't think I'm great at a lot of things
but I think I'm a great comedian mm-hmm
and I I one day I wanted to just be that
I don't want it to be like a great trans
comedian or a Vietnamese comedian or
whatever I think that's the biggest chip
on my shoulder I have right now well I
respect you for being honest about that
because I think that that's hard for
something beyond for people to be honest
about sometimes is a to say that we're
good about something without you know
sometimes our battle if like that's my
ego talk and if I were to say that or if
that's the low self confidence but to
say that you know and here you say that
I respect you saying that and I agree
like I saw your comedy and I didn't know
what to think of you like I didn't know
I met you through roast battle right you
know in roast battle four people aren't
familiar it's where two comedians
basically like insult each other right
with jokes and then judges get to judge
yeah and was that when Jim Carrey was
here no no no it was a different night I
think you were there the night I was
battling Conor McSpadden yeah yeah yes
yes I was and and I was like what I just
never seen anyone like you before
yeah you know and then after that I went
home and watched your comedy and I was
like holy [ __ ] this Lea this lady yeah
it's like this [ __ ] is kind of hardcore
a little bit yeah like transgender is
kind of a secondary thing but it's weird
cuz it's this thing you see first right
yeah yeah but it's not your only thing
right some people and this might be a
generalization I don't give a [ __ ] if it
is really but they hang their hat on oh
this is my thing right you know like
you'll meet gay guys in like I'm
you know more black people no I'm just
you know I'm you know you know you know
what I'm saying black power uh you know
brown power blacks forever we can't do
it we all we do is do it you know yeah
just like just hold on for a second guy
let me get on board here or you'll meet
a white guy that's just like you know
[ __ ] why you know Mianus [ __ ] this
you know we got to whiten up you know
I'm saying paint your [ __ ] friends
white dude yeah you know dip somebody in
[ __ ] white water yeah like what is
white water yeah but I got trans jokes
but they're always like they're always
like I switch to expectation of what I'm
gonna say like like I'll say like man I
want to be one of those trans I want to
be a trans woman they get start [ __ ] for
no reason like just walk into a store
and be like what isn't your women's
restroom have any urinals like I'll say
[ __ ] like that where is like that's not
a that's not a cool thing to say yeah
like I think it is cool because you're
not you're not taking the normal path of
like I'll be I'll save something that's
evil so that the crowd doesn't expect me
to just say nice things you know I'll
see a lot of evil [ __ ] huh I'll see you
I'll see if I can turn on to get them to
turn on me first and then I'll do comedy
to see to see how to see how good these
jokes really are well see that takes me
back to a little bit more of like do you
like it there's something been something
inside of me I know this in my life that
I wanted to make things and whether I
did it consciously or not that I wanted
to make things harder myself yeah
because there was something inside of me
that like if life wasn't like I was so
used to feeling some type of a hurt or
some type of a uncomfort right that if I
didn't keep things there somehow right
that I wasn't like I wouldn't even know
what was going on yeah I know what
you're saying but I think if I stayed as
Robert that would have been the hard
harder path mm-hmm this is the easier
path for me like the outside world might
be a little tougher but I feel like I
can look at people now you know and I'd
never give that up hmm so so you know so
there's no doubt that that that that's a
that this that this is your truth yeah
yeah well that's cool yeah cuz some
people I think a lot of times we walk
around is not knowing and maybe
sometimes if for some people it's a
gender thing for some people it's I
think you could even be like a job thing
you're in a job you know like I don't
this you know this doesn't fit me you
know you know I walk by a paint store
every day you know I just [ __ ] know
but you know yeah I want to be a painter
you know I think but you don't say I
think you know people don't know where
they fit no but I I still have that it's
just not with the gender thing I see
like you know I I had this moment about
rose petal like I'm like should I be
doing this like because like am i
selling out my my gender for laughs or
or am I being a badass and I'm stepping
in you know like I have that moment
where I'm like is this cool that I'm
doing this and I still like question
myself all the time like did I get this
opportunity because I'm whatever and
it's like and if I take it
am i a token but then I think like [ __ ]
it you know your life's been tough
enough just take it and then like blow
them away mmm
like like make it so that you got there
because of your gender or whatever and
then once we were there it's like wow we
should have actually just got you cuz
you were good you know it's funny you
say that because I think the same exact
thing sometimes about you know like
whenever I started in comedy I worked in
reality television you know this is a
kid I mean I was a kid at school right
basically won a contest you know and
ended up on on a show and I felt like
that I didn't even know what I wanted to
be or anything I didn't know that I
wanted to be a comedian yet yeah and
then people would judge me kind of for
that or have a look in their eye or have
a thing you know and it made it that's
the only thing that drove me for about
eight nine years yeah
was that I'm gonna show these people
that I'm [ __ ] good yeah yeah yeah I
have the same Drive yeah because I
didn't know that I wanted to be a
comedian yeah you know whatever was
going on before that I was a child 19
knows teenager
technically yeah and you know but I'm
gonna show these like it just that's
what put that chip on my shoulder that's
what made me that was my stand you know
yeah I think it's more like we get doors
open for us that wouldn't be normally
open and just like that's good but then
they look at you once the door is open
like alright we're just letting you in
because we want to see you yeah take a
peek yeah you almost we're almost let
you in just because we wanted to judge
you yeah yeah is how I feel a little bit
in that city's this city's full of that
yeah it's good it's crazy how gross it
is out here sometimes
even though it's supposed to be so
accepting do you notice any of that
oh I don't well I don't live in LA but
whenever I visit it feels like
everyone's trying to get on TV or like
everyone is acting like there's a camera
already on them they went to the in and
out with my girlfriend we were like
looking around it was like everyone here
is dressed up like they're on camera
like what the [ __ ] is this is so weird
like everywhere else like people are
like 1:00 in the morning you'd be
dressed in your pajamas or whatever you
know but that's how that's what I know
there's a lot of like plastic people
yeah yeah would you learn about love
from your girlfriend from staying with
you through that transition I learned
that some with anything if someone loves
you enough they'll stick by you through
anything that's that's like I don't know
I'm kind of blown away that she stuck
with me because I when I came out I was
like I'm about to throw away my
relationship that's what I thought
because people were thinking like Oh
what was this like a duo thing like you
know she's a feminist she does a joke
about it like people think that like she
made me like she's like whoa haha like
Frankenstein yeah yeah but it wasn't
that at all no I just learned that um no
no it's kind of corny but like love kind
of conquers all but I also learned that
if you love yourself enough you will
throw away everything to be who you are
the fact that I was able to like come
out like and go my mom might not love me
anymore my dad might not talk to me
anymore and my materials gonna be gone
my girl my girlfriend might leave me but
like I need to do this right now for me
that's that's what love is to me mm-hmm
yeah damn that's powerful it's so hard
for us to make choices and us that we
know we're the best Parcells yeah you
know that was an easy one for me it was
an easy one it wasn't it was easy as in
like I know this is what I got to do but
the consequences were gonna be the most
difficult
oh but looking at the stack and the
consequences that's when it really got
yeah
yeah it's so our man sometimes to make
the decision that we know is like are
the truest for us yeah you know or even
the right decision like in the face of
even little
like standing up for somebody whenever
somebody else's you know [ __ ] with
someone in your or making fun of
somebody and you're right there yeah you
know we're even like you know like when
someone like oh do you remember
so-and-so do you know so and so even if
you don't just be in let you're always
like yeah oh yeah I remember them or I
know them yeah you know it's like we
just don't want to be I don't know if
it's wrong we just I don't know are not
included we just we don't want anything
that makes us feel left out yeah no I
hear you I know what you're saying I
don't know I I guess I I guess I'm kind
of used to like not being part of a
group like I've always been the weird
one in the group every group I've ever
been in maybe he's on purpose I don't
know maybe I'm just pushing people away
for no reason who knows right like maybe
it's all subconscious do you get any
clues in any of that ever whenever I'm
in a group and I get comfortable I kind
of think like am I an individual anymore
like and and I kind of freaked out a
little bit like I like hanging out with
people one on one but in a group I get a
[ __ ] freak out dude like I don't want
to be part of a group I want to be my
own person
and so it's very isolating I said what
what are you scared of that the group
might would know that I might be part of
a group and I'm not myself anymore like
you look at a group you know and you can
write you can't be like oh that person
is the best or whatever because it's a
group it's a group you know I want to be
like an island like that's how that's
how [ __ ] good I am like I transcended
so that's that's kind of a mental
illness I think is like this narcissism
I have you know to want to be the best
and to want to be the most unique and
all that stuff mm-hm and to be away from
groups would you be surprised if
something else like so now you've
switched into a different gender if you
if you know you came up one day on took
it to it took you know found another
thing in life that makes us more unique
or more rare or more separate and you
chose that as well would you be shocked
if your brain started to lead you there
would you then think like oh maybe this
is a clue that you know there's
something going on that I'm not seeing I
don't know
and I'm not trying to lead you that I'm
just no no no I think I hear what you're
saying I think that the fact that
transgender is so rare is a coincidence
like if it was that if my truth was that
I am gay which is like kind of more
common now and I would have said that
you know like if I saw like there is
like a group of people who were like
they're gonna come out and there's even
less of them and they were even more
oppressed I wouldn't be like maybe I can
do that you know III don't think that
that would be the case yeah I would be
part of me that would be like me and
that would be [ __ ] awesome and I
could be even more unique of course that
exists yeah but it's not it wouldn't be
like I would go through that or I would
feel it or anything I've got a couple
questions I wrote and us on the way in
um
giving you regrets about about what
about my life about switching over to
being a woman nope
do you ever get the feeling that like
your body is just like a shell and that
there's that your being is more does
that make any sense I wish I did I hate
my body yeah [ __ ] gross yeah did you
hate it as much before as you do now
that's know if that hasn't changed has
it I bet it I hate it I hate it more
than I used to really because I'm more a
more critical of myself like when I came
out I started noticing all these like
pimples on my face like like I didn't
give a [ __ ] before as a guy and then as
a girl is like the only call you got to
cover that up
oh my god you know you got to cover up
the fat you got to get close it fit well
it were you more self-conscious now yeah
I'm Way more self-conscious now like
like when I feel fat that's when I wish
I was a guy cuz like feeling like a fat
girl is like really [ __ ] like awful
you know cuz bad girls get treated so
horribly oh you ever seen a fat girl eat
uh snow cone in the rain Oh beautiful do
you think that because now you're saying
like you feel more self-conscious as a
woman do you feel like there's something
inside of you that covets feeling more
rare or pushes you towards separation
yeah but I don't think that it has to do
with gender with gender
yeah you think so the so you're able to
notice like okay this was one thing yeah
that was definite and true and sure yeah
and then that these other things are
just regular things or just other things
about me yeah
I separate those things did you ever
concern the worry that that was one in
the same I feel like that would be a
huge concern then like holy [ __ ] I just
have this ego or something inside of me
no it never feel it never feels that way
I think it's more like people perceive
it that that could be it mm-hmm and then
I think I I could see where they're
coming from and I can't explain to them
how that's not the case you know that's
the frustration for me is I can't
explain how separate they are I think
you've done a good job here just talking
because it's very it makes I believe it
yeah and it's clear and that would be I
wasn't a concern however you came in is
just something I've thought about as
we're talking okay I remember when I was
young my brother and I'm there's a photo
of us putting on my mother's dress you
know cuz my mother raised us yeah and we
had on my mother's dresses and uh and he
had on we're on her bed like just
playing his kids you know and my brother
was very he had like kind of tan skin he
looked at people called us Mexicans all
the time cuz we had you know kind of you
know a little bit of olive skin right my
brother my brother was pretty dark yeah
they would call a [ __ ] and they would
use racial slurs but I mean there was
nobody around I was like [ __ ] yeah you
know you're only get called that because
you're basically you could've been in a
fire once and people are like look at
this [ __ ] you know what I'm saying like
those are third-degree burns okay
sometimes it's just we just difference
you know when people don't have anything
over there you know there's such on
education sometimes it's difference that
makes you a point yeah but I remember us
putting on these dresses and my mother's
and he had the kind of beige when her
the pink wouldn't I had the purple one
yeah and I'm [ __ ] honor all our
members out is remember man I bet he
wishes he had this purple yeah and I
don't know what that means I don't know
if it means anything yeah except that I
look back I look pretty good in a purple
you know I always loved pink man did you
I loved it I still do man like I wore a
pink top too like the first day of the
taping
oh yeah that's right you did that's the
first that's the first outfit I bought
what you saw that's why I have a special
like connection to it have any guys come
up tune our girls come to you and asked
you like for like advice in that world
yeah it's like how do you do your makeup
like how how do you accessorize no
advice in navigating your like
you know your own genes and thoughts and
you know no I get more asked for advice
about just like cosmetic stuff yeah yeah
yeah yes well I mean I feel like I'm
talking with a woman yeah because you
are you know yeah I like it too
yeah we got to do some shows one of
these ages come out on the road with me
somewhere I would love to and we don't
would your crowd like me you think yeah
I think no yeah Reza's here man he's
Latino dude and he's non-practicing
pretty much I always felt like the joke
I had the joke I had with Theo is that I
always like man our audiences probably
hate each other you know what I mean
like like the audience that likes me
probably doesn't like you and audience
that like you probably doesn't like me
like we both a bad haircut
I mean they're mine and when people saw
the picture of us together like they
were like in what [ __ ] universe are
these two hanging out so that you know I
would love to you man I'd love to go on
the road and do comedy and stuff yeah
well good all right cuz I'd love to take
you out there sometime do you feel like
other like diverse people like black
people are like aw [ __ ] this [ __ ]
Trump's us you don't have a saying do
you ever get that I feel like white guys
look at me that way yeah I think it's
like I don't want to say it's a hard
time for white guys in comedy but I'm
gonna say it's not really a commodity as
it used to be right like people are
looking for diversity now yeah but who
knows how long that'll last well it's
what made me think either like we need
some of this diverse and it's unique and
I was thinking well who would look kind
of unique to me who had come across as
smarter than me yeah and I was like
maybe this girl Robin Tran wouldn't do
it yeah and like he's heard realize him
really train I couldn't remember last
name and I'm like it's it's Tran yeah
with well that's one of my first jokes
yeah yeah it's my real name you know
it's not like you have to look far for
clues oh yeah yeah
I didn't just come out for the pun you
know that's a long way for a joke yeah
well thanks for coming here and just
sitting in and chatting with us and
thinking about stuff of course man
thanks so much for having me
yeah I appreciate it let's do it let's
do it again soon yeah sure I'd love to
um cool will put all Robins links and
everything at the bottom of the episode
and I'll see you guys this week I'm
gonna be in New Jersey I'll see you guys
there and what else I think that's it as
always thank our sponsor great block
pizza and anything else Chris cool
thanks man
yeah we don't have Chris miked up but
we'll get him miked up next time and
thank you guys for listening to Robin
thanks so much make so much for having
me man yeah I'll see you later thank you
[Music]